good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you're an incumbent
member of congress pretty much the last
thing you ever want to do is debate a
primary opponent in public
as a sitting member you already have
every possible advantage unless you drop
dead during a speech or get drunk and
take your clothes off on a commercial
airplane you are very likely to be
re-elected to congress so a televised
debate cannot help you it is all risk
and no upside
but occasionally there is no avoiding it
democrats held a primary debate in new
york city last night they had no choice
both the candidates in this race are
incumbents thanks to a court decision
that redrew congressional boundaries the
two most powerful members of the new
york delegation are now running against
each other for the same seat that's a
lot of fun
for 30 years carolyn maloney has
represented the upper east side of
manhattan over the same period 30 years
jerry nadler's represented the upper
west side of manhattan jerry nadler is
75 years old carol maloney is 76 years
old rather than do the obvious thing and
retire
the two are now competing for the newly
drawn 12th congressional district that
will combine the upper east side and the
upper west sides of manhattan
it turns out to be the richest district
in american politics four of the
democratic party's five top fundraising
zip codes are within this district's
boundaries
so there's a lot at stake and we forced
ourselves to watch the debate we are
richly rewarded for doing that we're
going to start with a headline from the
debate which you've already likely seen
neither one of these people is
cheerleading for joe biden he's carolyn
maloney
should president biden run again in 2024
yes mr nadler too early to say it
doesn't serve the purpose of the
democratic party to
to deal with that until after the
midterms miss maloney i don't believe
he's running for reelection
i don't believe he's running for
reelection that's what carol maloney
said well like everything she says it's
not exactly a profound observation of
course joe biden isn't running for
re-election he can barely find the men's
room the second the midterms are done he
will find a way to tell the rest of us
that so that was not very interesting it
was predictable what was very
interesting and what tells you a lot
about the democratic party
is how these two candidates talked about
their personal accomplishments and their
goals for the country
now we should tell you having watched it
that figuring out exactly what maloney
and nadal were trying to say was not
easy these are not spry articulate
people
they're not magicians with the english
language jerry nadler is so innervated
he had to sit for the entire debate
because he is too weak to stand
but at one point now they're gathered
the strength to boast about his greatest
accomplishment in the congress
that would be impeaching george w bush
twice
an insurrectionist republican party
for the first time in our history trying
to stop the peaceful transfer of power
now uh therefore i have i i am leading
the fight
to uh to stop this and that and i have
passed the um uh
two impeachments in my in leading this
i've impeached uh bush twice
there's twice
the secret to jerry nadler has never
been his appearance often remarked upon
it's been his intellect which is
small
obviously nadler meant to say donald
trump not that he can remember what
decade it is but what he meant to say is
not really a consolation for democrats
watching at home the problem here
is that jerry nadler and carolyn maloney
these are two of the most powerful
democrats in the united states congress
running in the most
influential district in the united
states of america neither of these
candidates have anything to say
so jerry nadler is asked what are you
proud of and he's talking about multiple
impeachments
whatever you think of impeachments did
they improve a single
life in this country no
so she was asked the same question carol
maloney what are you proud of what are
your priorities
and so she responded here are carolyn
maloney's priorities for the united
states
our work is not over yet
we need to protect women we need to pass
gun safety laws we need to combat
climate change
so those are her top predators this one
was powerful
sitting members of congress first party
protecting women in other words more
abortions protecting women from having
children so they can continue to work at
some depressing midtown bank
don't raise your family
go to work
what carol mullen does not mean by
protecting women of course is punishing
criminals they're free to beat women on
the subway in new york with no
consequences and they routinely do but
that's number one protecting women more
abortions okay number two gun safety
laws now none of these gun safety laws
meaning gun confiscation laws will be
enforced in places where the democrats
get a huge percentage of the vote like
chicago or baltimore new york or gary
indiana they get a pass but disarm the
other side and then number three
combating climate change
because you don't need air conditioning
in the summertime
you don't need a car
look at sri lanka they've done a great
job
what's interesting is what carol maloney
didn't mention as a top priority and
that would be the economy inflation
and it's interesting because every poll
taken shows that inflation is the number
one issue that actual americans care
about
so why wouldn't carol malone who's a
politician after all can probably read a
poll
why would she not include inflation
well it's possible she's not aware it's
happening and we know this from the
president of the san francisco fed that
would be married daily
she explained her views on inflation
inadvertently apparently she was unaware
she was being recorded and because she
didn't know anyone was listening daley
explained that inflation doesn't matter
to her because she's rich and we're
quoting i don't find myself in a space
that's how they talk in san francisco in
a space where i have to make trade-offs
because i have enough
and many americans have enough
oh you've got enough you've got enough
stop your whining
time to fix the climate we're in charge
of the weather now
so
these are the issues that the leaders of
the democratic party and the parties
donors many of them in san francisco and
new york care about they don't care
about inflation because they're rich and
it doesn't affect them in other words
they don't care about you
at all
and by the way this isn't just true of
long-standing establishment figures in
the democratic party like jerry nadler
and carol maloney it's everywhere it's
endemic it's in the fabric of the party
itself even people who want to join the
club repeat the same lines at the debate
last night maloney and nadler at 76 and
75 were joined by a 38 year old lawyer
called siraj patel now patel runs a
multi-million dollar hotel management
company
he was the guy on stage who's supposed
to be a breath of fresh air the face of
a new generation
so what did he talk about issues that
people care about
no
he referred back 15 years to describe
his so-called ideas because it turns out
he's an
obama democrat
my name is serge patel and i am a lawyer
a professor and an obama democrat from
whom i learned the democrats lead best
when we lead with new ideas energy and a
new generation of leadership
yeah that guy's got new ideas and energy
just like barack obama
that's why
he's supporting joe biden running for
re-election again it's pathetic
it's not just him it's not just maloney
it's not just poor jerry nadler
it's the entire democratic party the
democratic party has run out of gas
democratic party at this point is a
cartel that exists only to perpetuate
itself and the elderly mediocrities who
run and benefit from it
all of them carmella harris is only 57
years old she's a child by the standards
of her party but she still talks like a
dementia patient slowly and
incomprehensibly
here's carmella struggling to explain
what mail-in ballots are now you think
she would understand mail-in ballots
given that mail-in belts are why she has
a job but she doesn't they said when
they voted i think sometimes the voting
is you're just putting in your order
this is what you want
so when people stood in those lines for
hours
when they sat on their kitchen table
for hours figuring out how they were
going to fill out their ballot
to vote by mail
when they drove by those drop boxes with
their kids in the back seat
patiently waiting to to drop off that
ballot they were putting in an order
we don't mean to beat up on carmelo
harris who's obviously our favorite for
the democratic nomination next cycle
but she is a perfect distillation of
everybody in power in the democratic
party every word that emerges from
carmella harris's mouth
is a recycled talking point that's been
run through a banality machine to remove
the slightest hint of anything
interesting or challenging or relevant
or meaningful
so no wonder democrats are unpopular
they have nothing to offer they haven't
updated their files they believe it's
2005. you see this in foreign policy
particularly they are living in their
heads in a world in which the us wields
the world's most powerful military
backed by the world's strongest economy
and can do whatever it wants just by
telling other people to obey
so like joe biden you just tell russia
don't invade ukraine and of course it
won't we're america you just let china
know that we back taiwan and the entire
75 year old dispute over that island
will be settled forever they really
believe that they have no idea
of this country's relative place in the
world order because they don't know
anything
about reality as it stands right now
so here's nancy pelosi who imagines that
she's so powerful that she can somehow
bring about an indefinite piece in the
taiwan strait just by saying so watch
today our delegation of which i'm very
proud
came to taiwan to make unequivocally
clear
we will not abandon our commitment to
taiwan and we will proud of our enduring
friendship
it doesn't mean anything
it's the barking of dogs it's less
relevant than dogs barking and trust us
the chinese know that
but from nancy pelosi's perspective i
said it therefore it's going to happen
problem solved that's the world they
believe we still live in
they imagine the united states is still
so rich and fat powerful that we can
afford any sort of pointless frivolity
we can tamper with the formula and
suffer no ill effects we can hire trans
admirals and intersectional cia officers
and everything's gonna be fine that's
how powerful we are
we can force delta airlines and united
to apply affirmative action standards to
airline pilots and somehow our planes
will never crash
because
nothing bad ever happens in the world
these people have completely lost touch
with reality how out of touch are they
well the democratic party's main radical
right now is sandy cortez of westchester
how radical is sandy cortez well she
spends her days defending the intel
agencies and neocon foreign policy and
the big banks
so if your revolutionaries are reading
scripts written by the world economic
forum maybe they're not actually very
revolutionary maybe they're defending
the status quo and that's exactly what
they're doing
and they're doing it
because they have
no other plan the sad truth is the
people who run the democratic party have
just given up they've given up on the
country and given up on the people who
live here
they've got no solutions for you they're
not even pretending that they do climate
trans
they don't imagine a future
that's what they're telling you smoke
more weed
take more pills might as well cut off
your junk and pretend to be a girl
sterilize your kids abort your babies
there's no future worth having
that's not a caricature they're saying
that out loud
they're done
now the republican party by contrast is
suddenly showing signs of life of
thinking and responding to reality
they're faint signs trust me the people
who run it have no interest in changing
the republican party they've gotten rich
from it they're pretty happy with their
sinai cures
liz cheney and mitch mcconnell are
enraged by the changes they're content
with 2003 they'd like to invade iraq
again actually
mitch mcconnell's got pretty rich from
china doesn't want that to change
but they're not actually in control of
the party
the republican party is changing and we
know that for certain because last
night's election results in a couple of
primaries show
not just new faces but new ideas
blake masters won the republican primary
for senate in the state of arizona
candidates like peter meyer for example
of michigan
the guy who voted to allow men to play
in women's sports because he's sensitive
lost
in the republican primary for arizona's
gubernatorial race carrie lake has just
taken the lead
she's not like your parents republican
party and in the state of michigan tudor
dixon is now the republican nominee she
will take on gretchen whitmer in the
fall subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight